so let's get set to state halls theorem
in a way that doesn't mention boys and
girls but let's remember the girl boy
set up to start so in the general setup
is a bipartite graph H and a bipartite
graph has two sets of vertices the girl
vertices and the boy vertices formally
there's a set L of age called the left
vertices of H and a set R of H called
the right vertices of age the vertices
of H all together are elevates Union R
of H both of these are non empty and
they don't overlap then the edges of H
have the property that they only go
between L of H and R of H that is the
definition of a bipartite graph now
we're interested in a matching in a
bipartite graph so let's be precise
again of what's a matching without
having to mention boys and girls and
likes a match is a total injective
function from the left vertices to the
right vertices so that means every on L
vertex or girl has a match M of L that
is on the other side so and we we need
this total injective function match
function M to follow the edges what does
follow the edges mean precisely it
simply means that the edge L M of L is a
legitimate edge of H another way to say
that is that the graph of this total
injective function is a subset of the
edges of a so we can state the no
bottleneck condition halls condition as
follows if the size of s is less than or
equal to its image under the edges for
every set of left vertices H that's
called halls condition that the size of
s is less than or equal to the image of
s for every s then there is a match so
this is a way of precisely stating halls
theorem no boys and girls mentioned will
be comfortable going back to the
boy/girl language because it's it's more
memorable and easier to talk about but
just for the record we have now formally
stated defined bipartite graphs matches
in bipartite graphs and halls theorem
halls theorem really that
there is a match when halls condition is
satisfied without mentioning boys and
girls okay the puzzle is how do you
verify that there are no bottlenecks
it's pretty hard the bottleneck
condition involves checking that every
subset s of L of H satisfies this
cardinality condition and there are a
lot of subsets of L of H relative to the
size of the graph exponentially many so
we can ask how do you verify that there
are no bottlenecks well it turns out in
algorithms classes you will learn a
fairly efficient matching procedure runs
about quadratically for finding Mak
perfect matches when they exist but
there's one particular special case that
ensures no bottlenecks that will have to
make that will be making use of several
times in the term and that special
situation is when it turns out that
every girl likes at least D boys and
every boy likes at most D girls this is
called a degree constrained graph if a
graph is d constrained is degree
constrained then there are no
bottlenecks so this condition that there
are at least the each girl likes at
least D boys and every boy likes it at
most D girls could have been rephrased
as saying that the minimum degree of the
girls is greater than or equal to the
maximum degree of the boys but I think
expressing it in terms of D is maybe
makes it a little clearer okay let's
prove this I'm gonna prove that if you
have a deconstruct agree constrained
bipartite graph then in in fact
satisfies halls condition there are no
bottlenecks so we have that if every
girl likes at least D boys and every boy
likes and most D girls there are no
bottlenecks the proof goes as follows
let's look at some arbitrary set s of
girls and suppose that the total number
of edges that are incident to s are
it has cardinality e there are e edges
that touch vertices in s okay well that
tells us that since every vertex in s
has at least B edges out that may be
more the times the size of S has to be
less than or equal to the total number
of edges coming out of s likewise all of
the edges that come out of s go by
definition into a of s and each vertex
in a of s can only absorb the edges
TGIRLS so that means that the total
number of edges absorbed by E of s that
is at most the times a of s had better
be bigger than the number of edges that
have to be absorbed e so we get that d
times the size of s is less than or
equal to the total number of edges
incident to s which is less than or
equal to D times this total the total
number of vertices in a of s but cancel
the DS and we have that the size of s is
less than or equal to the size of its
image that's the definition of a
bottleneck the violation of that would
be a bottleneck this says there's no
bottlenecks and we have proved the
degree constrained condition is
sufficient to verify halls condition and
by halls theorem it's sufficient to
guarantee that there is a match now
there's a lot of graphs with matches
that are not degree constrained this is
not an if and only if theorem it's just
a sufficient condition that comes up
often enough that it's worth mentioning
the Greek constrained implies halls
condition is satisfied which implies
that there's a perfect match so let's
turn now to the general case of halls
theorem and let's talk about proving
halls theorem halls theorem says that if
there's no bottleneck then there is a
match so let's begin by setting up a
lemma that will play a crucial role the
strategy for showing for proving it is
basically going to be to try to break
the problem of finding a match for a
large set of vertices into subproblems
of finding matches for smaller sets
vertices and by-and-by strong induction
halls condition will apply to the
subsets and will win let's look at that
more carefully so let's begin by
supposing that there are no bottlenecks
in some bipartite graph H well in
particular if there's no bottlenecks
anywhere then if you restrict yourself
to some set s of girls no subset of that
set s is gonna have a bottleneck
obviously because a bottleneck within s
would be a bottleneck within the whole
graph so that part's trivial what's not
trivial and takes a little bit of
arguing is that suppose you have a set
of girls that with the property that the
number of boys that are compatible with
that set of girls is exactly the same as
the number of girls so technically the
size of s is equal to the size of a of s
in that case we can argue that there
aren't any bottlenecks within the
complement of s and the complement of V
of s either well let's look at a picture
to illustrate what's going on so here we
have a bipartite graph and there's s and
it's image on the right a of s ok now
we're interested in and we know that a
bottleneck here would imply a bottleneck
in the whole graph what we want to argue
is that a bottleneck in the compliment
of s would imply a bottleneck in the
complement of V of s so there's the
complement of e of s and there's the
complement of s now notice that some
edges that come out of the complement of
s may very well go into e of s that is
this would be a point that's both in E
of s and in e of s complement but we're
not allowed to use that point because
we're trying to find a match only within
s bar and E of s bar and and what we're
really trying to argue is that a
bottleneck here would imply a bottleneck
in the whole graph so let's see if we
can argue this there's no we want to
claim that there's no bottleneck between
s bar and EF s bar given that there's no
bottleneck anywhere and
when s and e of s are the same size so
let's suppose that we had a set T over
here that was a subset of s bar and
let's look at its image over here in
orange so we've got that the image of
this set T when we restricted just to
the part that's in the complement of s
notice I'm leaving out this point here
I'm not taking the image of T I'm taking
the image of T restricted to the points
that are not in the image of ass and
what I want to know is could that cause
a bottleneck after all I've left out
some points that used to be included in
the image of T and so the image of T
might have been small so the image of T
might have been bigger than T because of
those extra points that I'm leaving out
I have to be sure that that doesn't
happen could there be a bottleneck
that has been created by these points
that I've left out could there be a
bottleneck in a of T intersection a
compliment of e of s could that orange
guide be a bottleneck
well if it was a bottleneck then I'd
have a bottleneck in the whole graph and
that's because s and e of s are the same
size because all I do is if I had a
bottleneck there I would take this set T
along with s and this set orange along
with a of s and that would be a
bottleneck because now if you look at
the size of T I've added the same amount
to the size of T as I've added to that
arm set because e of s and s are the
same size so if this orange part was
smaller than T then orange part along
with e of s is smaller than T Union s
and that defines a bottleneck in the
whole graph so again if there was a
bottleneck in here caused by restricting
images to the compliment to V of s it
means that was a bottleneck in the whole
graph if there's no bottleneck at all
then indeed there's no bottleneck in
this other part of the complement of s
and the complement of V of s and this
gives me a hook on proving halls theorem
because that's basically the way I'm
going to split the problem into two
separate matching parts so let's now
proceed to prove
if there are no bottlenecks in a graph
then there's a perfect match and it's
going to be by strong induction on the
number of girls so case one is the case
that we just examined that there's a
non-empty subset of girls a proper
subset not all the girls some subset of
girls know who that another way to say
it is there's a subset of girls that's
not empty and it's complement does not
empty either and the size of s is the
same as the size of EFS that is the
number of boys that are compatible with
this set of girls is exactly the same
size as this set of girls well if
there's going to be a match there has to
be one in that subset and um by the
lemmas they'll be if there's no
bottlenecks anywhere there's no
bottlenecks when I restrict myself to
just s and e of s and also by the
previous lemma
there's no bottleneck in the complement
of s and restricted to the the vertices
in EFS so this is a new bipartite graph
where I'm using s for the left vertices
and E of s for the right vertices and
here I'm using the complement of s for
the left vertices and the complement of
e of s for the right vertices and we and
the previous lemma says that if there's
no bottlenecks overall there's no
bottlenecks in either of these two
restricted graphs so what I can do now
is by induction since there's no
bottlenecks in se of s I can find a
match there so I can match up all of the
girls in s with compatible boys in II of
s and I can match up all of the girls
that are not in s in the complement of s
with boys that I haven't used already
and there'll be a perfect match there
and then these two separately will
combine will provide a match for the
entire set of left vertices s Union the
complement of s will be all of the
vertices so and these two matchings
don't overlap so they they're combining
them gives a complete matching that
knocks off this case that's the nice
case where I can find some subset where
the number of boys is exactly equal to
the number of girls which means that
that has to work by itself and
work that one by itself and what's left
over by itself and that's how I can find
an overall match the second case is that
there isn't any set of girls which are
compatible with exactly the same number
of boys well since halls condition holds
that means that every set of girls
actually has to be compatible with a
larger set of boys than the number of
girls that is for every set s the size
of s is strictly less than the size of
EFS for every non-empty and proper
subset s well in that case actually
finding a match is easy because now I've
got slack what I can do is just pick an
arbitrary girl caller G and she's got to
be compatible with it with at least one
boy because there's no bottlenecks in
fact in this case you'll actually be
compatible with at least two boys but
all we need is one boy since there's no
bottlenecks if I pick a girl she's got
to be compatible with some boy and I'm
just going to arbitrarily match her with
that boy match G with B now the
consequence of that is that if I now
remove G and B from the graph I am left
with a graph in which at worst I've
shrunk the set e of s by that girl that
I've matched with B which means that P
of S which used to be strictly greater
than s has gone down by at most one it's
still greater than or equal to e of s so
I'm left then the graph after I've
removed this G with paired with an
arbitrary be that she's compatible with
I'm left with a graph that satisfies
halls condition and that has one fewer
boy hurt that girl vertex and so it has
no bottlenecks and therefore it has a
match and that match in the sub graph
where I've taken out G and B when I put
back the match when I add the part of G
matching with B it's a match for the
whole graph and that's how I get it that
completes the proof of halls theorem